Тьоть Валя!
Тьоть Валічка, а йдіть сюди, будь ласка.
— Що за делегацію ти привела? Картоплю мити?
— Так!
— Насипаємо зараз.
— Тьоть Валічка, якраз до картоплі привела.
— Покажіть, ви ж, я бачу, копаєте.
— Що показати? Копати?
— Ідіть покажете. Ну, підіть.
— Та куди? На город іти?
Ой, Боже мій, оце так! Попала баба!
Ось плантації, які ми копаємо.
То з того боку була рання. То вже викопали.
А це — пізня. То буде на осінь.
«Тірас», «Берегиня», «Слов'янка»
і «Джерело Полісся». Все.
Ага. І «Багряна» ось ще.
Скільки у селі живемо —
стільки і картоплею займаємось.
Що ж у нас? Який бізнес? Оце такий.
Замочуємо, будемо мити, пакувати
і везти в Черкаси на гуртовий фермерський базар.
І там продаємо тим, хто купляє.
На гуртовому купляють десь на магазини.
Води. Води лийте в стільки балій.
— Добрий день!
Сюди насипаємо. Мию.
Надіваємо гумові рукавиці, та колошмачу її у воді,
а тоді — на ряднинах розстеляємо,
сушимо і в мішки складаємо.
Оце! Як і всі.
Таке туристично-розважальне подвір'я для дітей.
Дітки приїжджають на день, скажімо, десь із міста:
із Черкас, із Кропивницького приїжджають.
І розважаються цілий день.
Ми тут дізнаємося про історію
приходу картоплі в Україну.
Дізнаємося про властивості крохмалю.
Розповідаємо про сорти картоплі.
Взагалі [розповідаємо] про Головківку:
чим займаються у селі Головківка.
Робимо хімічні досліди, фізичні досліди,
як добуваємо електроенергію з картоплі.
Хатка — дуже старенька, автентична:
мазана глиняна, і двері
тут такі сторічні, дубові.
Як можна подивитися на якийсь продукт
або на якусь іншу тему з іншого боку?
Наприклад, якщо на картоплю...
То не подивитись на неї як на їжу,
а обіграти якось її в іншому плані,
для того, щоб діткам було цікаво
на цю тематику щось дізнатися, погратися.
Раніше садив півтора гектара картоплі.
Зараз трохи зменшив площі.
Взагалі, у нас Головківка — це картопляне село.
Завжди, із давніх-давен всі займаються картоплею.
У нас землі дуже підходять для вирощування картоплі.
На цій землі дуже вона виходить смачна. Картопля.
Бо навіть завозили сорти,
які не мали великих смакових якостей.
А на нашій землі, через два-три роки,
вона набувала смакових властивостей набагато більших.
Це вже перевірено.
Картопля передалася по спадковості.
Нас батьки привчили її вирощувати.
Так, видно, в генах заклалося.
Я і своїх. У мене — два сина.
Один у Києві навчається, один — ще в школі.
Ну, хоч і в Києві навчається,
та все одно потяг до землі є.
Бо, видно, теж передається і їм.
Олю!
Олічко, іди до нас, будь ласка.
— Добрий день!
Картоплі у мене чотири сорти:
«Білоруса», «Берегиня», «Слов'янка» і «Рів'єра».
Батьки займалися, возили скрізь цю картоплю.
Вантажили на великі фури.
Такі мішки були, їх уже в нас нема.
Мішки по 100 кг, 103 кг.
Була дуже велика картопля.
Тоді гарно родила: краще ніж зараз.
Город був дужче огноєний,
тому що була скотина.
Вихідні — не відпустка:
сіно дідові косили.
Ох, блін!
[сміється]
Не записуй!
Як сіно косив, та?
Як така спека. По такій жарі —
35 [градусів] — косити косою вручну.
А зараз оно косилки ці.
Зараз легше вже. Тракторів скільки.
Заплатив. Він тобі скосить,
згребе і в тюки  [поскладає].
Ось розказує сусідка, що оце все, дивися, хата, повітка —
все, що тут, — це все за картоплю.
А тут із давніх-давен картоплею займаються.
Бо тут родить картопля.
Полуниця тут не родить.
А тут чорнозем. Чорнозем не хоче.
Таке картопляне село.
Є у мене унікальна картопля: синя.
Ви бачили?
Не тільки зовні синя, а і в середині.
Зараз я вам її знайду.
Ми — картопляні.
У будь-якому вигляді:
і в шкірці, і пюре, і смажена.
Картопля — це найперше, що у нас є на столі.
Не тому що вирощуємо,
а тому що ми любимо її.